he's more of a yellow stone man i'm a
little huddy kind of guy i'm team huddy
who's hunting exactly exactly was he a
soundcloud rapper because i want to know
lil hottie what up the hottie me tim
dill and hottie all hanging nice
little hottie was a tick tock star yeah
he was dating um
trippy red
no uh cashie 6'9 the charlie demon
demolia girl
the main tick tock chick was one girl
and they were dating i thought it was
just he's part of the hype house i don't
have to explain everything i thought it
was jessica
who that's jessica rabbit no
[Laughter]
man that was my dream role when i was a
kid
not jessica rabbit her ass yeah no to
play the the bob hoss control that's
what i wanted that that never did it for
me roger rabbit the the real world the
[ __ ] cartoon zip it give me all or
nothing here give me shawshank or
bobby's world what on the low i didn't
see it till years later i was not swept
up in it at all i wasn't swept up in
aladdin either
none of that [ __ ] did it for me kick
rocks i totally mermaid came out like
hell it was just another day of school
for me give me a guy with some trials
and tribulations you know what i mean
like somebody who can't pay rent or you
gotta [ __ ] rob a bank or something
these [ __ ] cartoons never and they
don't do it for me now either these
goddamn superheroes kick rocks i'm
starting to become
well i don't want to defame it too much
but you're gonna intro this show at all
you're [ __ ] hosting oh hey everybody
and welcome back to them hard
[ __ ] feelings i'm your host
stage foley i'm here with kevin james
ryan hello toby mcmuffin is in the
building oh yeah let's get into it
tonight on a hard feeling
shake the cameras
now there's [ __ ] with the ten rings
i'm losing now uh i need a guy i need a
guy i need a guy i can't relate and i
guess talking about with movies talking
about movies here movies jerry after
spider-man i don't know i'm i'm i'm my
guy how many footage can you see a guy's
[ __ ] zip across the world give me
real life consequences
the guy's shooting [ __ ] webs out of
his hand i'm supposed to believe that
like they just fought chapter 11. yeah
that's so cool he took his kids so
insane
anyway yeah it's no good i'm off the
superheroes [ __ ] them you know what is
great i watched last night
rounders classic what you've never seen
rounds no i've seen it a million times
do you mean my identity from 2002 to
2007 which is why i wanted to bring it
up everybody kippy tell me you didn't
get into poker after you saw rounders uh
no i got into poker through chris
moneymaker when he made the when he won
the world series of poker i believe in
2003 let's call 2002. uh and then at
that time rounders had boiler room and
then rounders and then we created our
own casino
you're a young kid let me take you back
to that age 32
which i called the most brutal age of
all it was post 9 11.
all right a lot of people remember next
sucked a lot of people couldn't get good
peter to save my life i just did get
discontinued
yeah hummus out the door after 9 11. uh
a lot of people were it seemed to me
like a lot of people were like starting
to move back home
move back just your dirtbag friends
who all busted out
they did all the blow on the upper east
side so they had to go back to the
suburbs with mon paw bus
yeah you get out of here your your
[ __ ] worldview is so [ __ ] skewed
so anyway as i was saying don't listen
to him
you know it is too i'm giving you the
skinny
nothing about you skinny so everybody
was moving back home
everybody was like doing
i don't know whatever hold on no stop
this is how you describe things
everybody was moving back home who's
everybody did you say whom
[Laughter]
hey horton zip it will you
telling a tale over here who's everybody
trying to chat this long air up it feels
like okay no not it feels give me
everybody you got a name at least all
right all right jesus can i get a glass
of water if we're saying everybody i
need at least six people all right six
exactly
you're doing your dirtbag friends can i
use you guys
[Laughter]
hold on a second he's stink it was okay
so i'm 45. at around that time people
were starting to get married uh buy
houses and stuff like that how old were
you in 2003 2000
it was 20 years ago you were 25 25 26
22. so people were starting to get
married they were starting to settle
down they were all doing like the
suburban life thing where they would
have a party this one would have a party
that kind of thing and every [ __ ] i
just had my tunes man every [ __ ] dude
they'd show up with the [ __ ]
briefcase with their chips
yeah sorry we're trying to wet our beak
a little bit take for a little bit of
school texas hold'em was real big yeah
yeah of course
some say the only pure game left
let me tell you something those guys are
you talking about doyle
shout out to doyle brunson
i know malkovich
what's the oil what's soil
that's insane ten deuce come on that's
the brunson yeah of course
offsuit you want two [ __ ] worlds
you're driving up the same hand
let me get a hose and hose you down like
like a whale getting shipped from tank
to tank
i was gonna say if i'm abroad at the bar
i'm moving on to the next guys you two
stink i'm talking about rounders
yeah rounds is a great movie and i'll
tell you damon betty taylor the other
guy
norton yeah of course let me tell you
another thing that's it all right my
tell me to tell me to tell me the thing
my hoodie weren't friends sure those
bozos that i see on espn for some reason
in the middle of the day at like the
world series of this in the world series
that i want to smack this [ __ ] at
everyone they're all [ __ ] [ __ ] they
have their hoodies and their sunglasses
on they're being real snarky to each
other they look that's what smack them
so i don't like it
i don't like the home poker thing or
whatever you don't know how to play uno
like a gentleman
you don't know how to play do you play
what
cards poker
there's like 45 different versions of it
it's all the same game of poker yeah i
get it i know how to play poker deuces
aces one-eyed faces
dead man's hand all i need is a chip and
a chair
oh man
uh
yeah
it's stunk i played hold'em from time to
time that's what it was like back then
you would have you would have hated it i
mean dude first of all you act like
you're hanging out a lot of royal blue
button downs yeah well i do yeah there
was a lot of max
shout out to express a lot of maxim
magazines
also like you
could do no wrong you paint this picture
like you were cool you were a [ __ ]
you were a zilch living with his parents
yeah you were a drug addict no i wasn't
i was living in new york on my own with
my brother you said you didn't leave
your apartment for like 18 months one
time i still lived there you were a
shut-in and that everyone moved away
yeah
and was doing i don't know stuff is what
he said
and no whatever everybody seemed to be
doing whatever i was watching
from a distance
i was like nick cage in city of angels
uh yeah there was like a huge that was a
good thing about the other 2000s what a
movie that there was a huge obviously
like cultural like the culture behind it
uh douchebags yes poker bros do suck but
anybody
anybody that
latches on to anything like that is a
doesn't have an identity themselves i
got swept up in that game where you
bounce the ball on the on the little
trampoline what
that was like a craze a couple summers
ago spike balls spike ball yeah spike
ball's all right
you got wrapped up in that what do you
mean you haven't been to the beach in
six years what are you talking about i
played it a couple of times
i could see there in astoria i could no
have my parents some one of them you
guys are playing in the backyard oof
that's a beach only game buddy kids were
playing on the driveway yikes
holy [ __ ] was a stickball court closed
what do you mean
[Laughter]
throwing half a wiffle ball at you
jesus we used to play half ball
yeah we didn't play uh not stickball
half ball
real south philly old school [ __ ] yeah a
half a tennis ball tennis ball [ __ ]
broomstick up in new york they got a
real skinny stick real big ball down
here in philly we got a real big stick
well half ball half ball there was a
half ball there was an art to it there
was an arc to the way you threw it you
had to like you saucer it in
you could really get a piece of that
thing if you kept that at the end of the
broom
good night
yeah they used to play when uh anyway
back to your mahjong game or whatever
you were talking about i was playing
high stakes
we were man we were you didn't have high
stakes exactly that's what makes it even
more high stakes you play all right so
you would sit down at like a [ __ ] we
just put in a couple hundred like a
hundred bucks or whatever like three or
four of us
at a casino no you'd be pl i mean yeah
no you'll be playing online if you're
playing with like a team
or we would go to the casinos but when
you came is it friday night
no this is whatever
wednesday
yeah i mean we used to go to the [ __ ]
casinos during we used to drive down
atlantic city during the week when we
were 17.
it was breaking out the circus certain
that's whatever it was the west circuit
circus
the really wild west after don't let
anybody in there there's infants dealing
it's crazy
a couple of times there's still remnants
of that place too there's still some
murals up outside it's connected to
whatever we do the shows that i'm
connected to the club to the hotel we
did shows at i want to hear how you how
did your team on
online so there'd be like three or four
of us right you know naked
i'm bottomless
uh
just bottoms this is great
hippie's wild
i got two pair
hey i got a set of deuces
full boat i got some low hanging eights
i got tight eights
i got a set of tight eights wired
oh sometimes you guys say [ __ ] on this
one it's a shame it's mine to pay well
but it is
no leaksies
chicken sandwiches
um
no see what play you get like
we would do this typically if we were
like gambling on like you know uh
college football or what like we would
go through phases where we're really
[ __ ] gambling
and i don't know why you rolled your
eyes at that you act like you're sam
math rosting you're no you you're a
couple of suburban punks listen to
anybody their parents anybody that's
ever done anything and says they did it
you go oh this guy's done something you
believe this guy anytime anybody says oh
i've done this it's like if it's
something cheesy yeah gambling on if you
guys said you were playing paintball or
at a monster truck show i'll be like
that's pretty sweet so gambling on cal
watching college football and gambling
with your boys not gambling in college
football that's literally what i just
said
i mixed it in with the poker i know
that's what i'm saying he's all wearing
khakis what's going on i was a jean man
through and through um
but
so we'd be playing [ __ ] and then like
at the end of the night the games are
over so like you can't there's no more
[ __ ] action but you've been juiced up
all [ __ ] day chasing the dragon you
know
but like poker stars or whatever you put
a couple hundred bucks on there
everybody throws up like 100 bucks 200
bucks whatever
and then uh
you sit like a [ __ ] regardless of how
much money you have you said it like a
one two game like a one two no limit
game like a smaller game and then you
you know steal a couple of [ __ ] big
pots and you
level up level up level up
until we were playing like five we'd be
sitting we'd sit down with like three or
four grand i guess the guy who had like
35 000 and you just try to at that point
you're just hoping to get a [ __ ] oh
yeah hoping to get a hand quick and get
the [ __ ] out because like each hand's
costing like [ __ ] 100 bucks just to
stay in
that's what we would do and then right
three i mean now you get like 11 bets
now it's like three in the morning your
[ __ ] [ __ ] house wasted
and things get a little reckless you
know you start firing and then you know
what's the most you ever made
probably
four million yeah um
i don't know probably we saw
chopped up a couple thousand dollars
from a couple hundred bucks each okay
yeah
i had a buddy in high school made 16. i
don't know why you get so weird any time
okay
okay i just think i
think what
yeah
i mean also 21 is different somebody
could sit there and be like half checks
hey thinking about being a 27 year old
drug addict is also not the coolest
thing in the world i never said it was i
never said i never said anything i'd do
is the coolest thing in the world either
seem pretty good about it no that's how
you internalize it i could be like yeah
i used to you know i've done this once
you left
this guy over here this guy i like 21 i
like roulette you don't like any of that
we've been to the casino six months ago
and you acted like an undercover cop
you literally stink i don't know i
thought you would have i thought you had
gotten 200 chips that's why you were out
of control
you had the fever you probably i'm not
you're not going to vegas when people
when people do stuff you don't like
having fun
discuss if you can okay when people are
doing cool stuff yeah you're always
rolling your eyes dragging your feet why
are you doing this why let's go to the
stuff oh the diner's cool
that's i mean you literally cried on the
way into the water that gave you a
transformative experience in hawaii
okay enough i mean dude you're in hawaii
everybody's jumping off a boat doing
backflips making out with jigs you're
hanging off the back crying
you stink
literally you have road blocks up around
every aspect of everything
folks the reports are coming in
nothing's concrete yet but i have it
over the wire uh apparently i stink
this is in from chopper 4. yeah
i still don't like caught it i didn't
like that time i i'm literally not
saying yeah i just say i didn't like
that everybody's showing up with their
own chips listen first of all dude if
you're shocked making everybody play
making a spend ruining the party then
you're from something they set it up and
then come on you gotta do it then
they're all smoking cigars you're
friends who the [ __ ] are you your
friends stunned not my immediate friends
oh see now here we go that that does
stink because they said yeah that's a
bad party yeah you should have been
getting together to play the card yeah
you're like that's like i'd be like
busting out like a basement like hey
listen to me play music well there you
go that's what turned me off from it
anytime there was this a football party
something pretty
somebody had to show up with [ __ ] hey
let's play
never that's insane that's [ __ ]
that's the worst anybody somebody tries
to bust out a board game they're like
you listen to the rules it's like kick
rocks let me hang out over here smoke
some ciggies that's like a little jenga
every once in a while i'm not gonna lie
little jumbo jenkins there's a great bar
uh up uh up in washington heights no
there's not on one party
i don't like bars do they serve hot dogs
they actually do they have a great hot
dog really called the wallace at the
wallace you've been right next door
remember when my first like a coffee my
first night in new york
and we met at that bar in harlem public
time you saw on the show at the coffee
place yes right down from the coffee
place we met at that bar yes right next
to that it's like it's sister bar it's
the same owners i think i've been to
that bar called the wallace
with me a dominican friend of ours
yeah we had a couple beers in there one
night
you've been up there yeah that one what
what were you doing was you you idiot
yeah but why were we both up there i
don't know
this ain't checking out
tough break ball you'll never catch me
well that's a good bar they have cute
they have like a life size not life size
but like bigger jenga which is a good
time if you're hanging but you go there
to play games if you go to a party and
someone's trying to push [ __ ]
something on you that wasn't organized
hey we're having a game night come by
hey the boys are playing poker come by
we're gonna do pictionary come by sure
if that's what you go sign up but are
you gonna sign up for a [ __ ] house
party and someone's like
pushing some [ __ ] whack ass game on
you kick rocks with that okay
i like games at parties though
i think like if you're going like hey
does everybody want to play this but
like to someone set up a [ __ ] poker
game i would even do it so that's why i
got a bad impression of it some dice
maybe that's
[Laughter]
shout out to seven eleven uh not seven
eleven uh left right center left right
center is a great game do you ever play
that
i don't like dice i knew a guy who
played dice one time and he gave me a
wedgie i'm done i like that no i think
this is more in the vein of like no i
don't take left turns yeah
or some [ __ ] like that
i'm crazy i take a lot you stink
it's literally like
it's literally navigating a psychotic
minefield having a conversation with you
what's left right center left right
center is a
game of dice
uh you play with like a big group it's
like no commitment it's like literally
it takes a round takes
three minutes or something if so if you
want to play you play
uh it's just like the money passes
around you got to be the last guy with
all the money oh yeah he like passes
around in circle left right and this is
a good time you can play it as a
drinking game the whole nine years i got
you how good drinking i've played that
before i got nothing wrong with a good
drinking if people are playing i wasn't
a beer pong guy
yeah
hey you're not like a fun guy you're not
i hated that [ __ ] in college
yeah it was always dumb that going to
the bars
going to the bars is dumb that sucked
i like having doing having parties doing
drugs in a room yeah
i mean like dude listen try that real
fan of a snowstorm in july yeah
[Laughter]
running the slalom
doing drugs with your lipstick
that's all you like doing man
you like two people
listen every decade you get three new
friends and they wash out the old
friends and you just hang in a room and
don't do anything and do drugs yeah i
like that yeah
so i can see why if you're not in the
confines of your own room doing drugs
and you're forced to hang out in public
with people doing cool stuff it can be a
little annoying
if they're preventing you from doing
what you like to do can you believe
these guys spending money on a game
they've been spending that money on
drugs
here they are playing cards they're not
really doing coke or anything
oh [ __ ] what's the point
shout out to drugs in a room
today's episode of hard feelings is
brought to you by that i think we i
think we just really boiled down why you
hate doing everything so much if it's
not drugs in a room
really
i mean you've seen i've been dealing
with it for a decade but you've seen it
like the thing zach anybody doing
anything gets a right away is a bad
thing well let's say this and let's be
honest 100 percent of the time
we can meet the airport some guys get as
long as you believe this guy pulling his
[ __ ] luggage wait he's doing a thing
toby will back me up on this
and i'll tell you what toby i want you
to look inside yourself and i want you
to be honest be honest with me i'm
always an impartial
is anything better than drugs and around
drugs in a room
let's let's be honest is anything but
also let me he's raising a point let me
also raise a point toby loves doing
stuff toby's a big dude drugs he likes
doing drugs no he likes doing drugs so
much does it look like he can't do drugs
i know you shouldn't
i will i will say this
drugs in a room
does rip sure drugs in a room okay
that's all right can i can i can i
counter
with with another
thing that's pretty great what drugs
outside is pretty good
maybe next year
maybe next year the big man i'll give
you put his outdoor pants on because
when when we went we went to when we
went around in austin that saturday
sure drugs on a bike
drugs in a lake
drugs in a restaurant
drugs in an elevator made a weird for a
minute
that was bad drugs in an elevator
drugs in an elevator is no good
drugs in our rooms are right drugs
outside's all right drugs in an elevator
can go real well i mean it was also it
took nine hours to find out you were on
drugs which i gotta give you drugs in
private
[Laughter]
secret drugs
also that's probably that that beats for
me personally that beats drugs in a room
is doing tons of drugs and then no one
knows you're on drugs is like the best
sneaky drugs yeah sneaky drugs secret
drugs sneaky secret drugs is all right
sneaker drugs is okay for a while but
believe me it wears on yeah i can tell
you information yeah it's the law of
diminishing returns quickly yeah it's
not that it's very telltale heart um
but drugs outside
is pretty good
but if i had to say
drugs in a room on a winter on a
winter's night drugs in a low-lit room
it's pretty good man i
i'm this is like an epiphany i feel i
feel cleansed that i finally figured out
why you ate everything this is something
like the drugs in the room yes if it's
not drugs in a room you [ __ ] dig your
heels in and just have so much
resistance
man this is i feel like a new light it's
no longer fully complaining it's drugs
in a room drugs in a room i can just go
i get it he does he's not doing drugs in
a room
he'll get over in a couple of minutes
well we get to i mean dude you can't
he'll be doing drugs in a room you
literally kick and scream with anything
it's great yeah
usually wrong about a lot of stuff too
literally everything
literally
everything except for drugs
come on now
come on now
big dur guy
i remember i remember
doing opium in our fraternity house
completely overrated
it was good it was really good opium we
were having a huge party
everybody was downstairs having a good
time there was like seven of us
in the front like bedroom like the cool
bedroom on the second floor it had like
the [ __ ] traffic light and all the
stop signs and a lot of stuff it was
very fraternity 90s
and you think that's cool
a stoplight and a stop sign in a room
that's like out of central casting i'm
just telling you man that stinks
if you invited me over to your room and
there's a stop sign i'd leave but he
forgot about the most important thing
about the group drugs in a room there
were the drugs of the right i would go
get my own drugs in my own room it's
pretty cool when you would on opium that
traffic light's pretty sweet
i remember somebody coming in being like
what are you guys doing
drugs in a room
i don't know but shut the door
i got weed in here
you should castanza it you should
all of your gut instincts are wrong
okay
so then the opposite pertaining to
regular life
yeah what do you mean
yeah what else would we be talking about
i don't know whatever fullyville who
knows what goes on over there
your all of your instincts to like
something or hate something are wrong
right we can we can write that as fact
i'm right a couple of times about people
very
you're i mean as many times as you go
[ __ ] this person [ __ ] that person [ __ ]
him [ __ ] terror [ __ ] this guy [ __ ] her
over there and then you meet them and
you go that's a great guy you know who i
hung out with great guy we're best
friends if i was to do it if i was a
dictator there would be a lot of
innocent blood on it yes yes i think
that's what you can say
yeah not a lot of stays of execution
going on over there kill him
so
hello kill him if you're if you're if
you feel like i hate that person you
probably just like them you know turn it
you're wrong just tell you your brain
tells your gut that you're wrong
you see what i'm saying you're afraid to
go swimming they're currently they go
into bar stink you think this that
that's not fun going on a hike is stupid
i thought i think disney stinks and
we're going
we're going we're going i'm gonna be
excited
i wanted to bring something up about
that
if i may sure stop doing that that's my
thing
this guy
it's like [ __ ] the talent of mr rip
this guy's gonna murder me i i don't
know if i could get away with it i would
do it trust me really
shoot me straight and you're farting
over there no not at all something's
happening i swear to god is my breath
oh it could be the onion something
all right moving on is that what it is
oh we cut this i don't know what it is i
felt like my breath smelled really bad
when we did uh sdr and i was sitting
right now that was a joke a week and a
half ago so that should we should be
worried about that still
it was really bad
uh this is me i do this i literally do
this
i
play this game you ever do potatoes one
potato two potatoes three potatoes four
or five three six days seventh day or
then you break them in a half
kind of no you didn't do potatoes yeah i
decided everything yeah you might we
were uh eeny meeny miny moe family
did you do the end part the impart was
[ __ ] if he hollers let him go eeny
meeny mi that was my mother told me to
dump it up yeah no we played we were old
school rules we were street rolls street
ball
yeah i know that an inkadink rocks
i'm it it's bad
anywho
i've been thinking about the uh disney
world trip i've been planning i got i
just got to pull the trigger on
everything well here's the thing
and i'm just
thinking out loud here okay also we just
said every instinct you have is wrong
okay so let's maybe think the opposite
might be right all right let me air it
first and then see what you guys think
sure i okay and this isn't even that
kind of thing i don't think i feel a
little guilty or a little weird
going to disney world without a kid
what are you talking about we're
bringing a giant baby yeah i'm going
with i'm going with the world's largest
baby we're gonna crown you when we get
there
put a blue ribbon on you oh that means
i'm gonna [ __ ] in my pants all weekend
uh i thought that was great drink your
food
um what can we bring a kid
[Laughter]
i was off whatever this was gonna be and
i am so [ __ ] in who's gonna send us a
kid
no obviously not not that uh like a a
nephew a cousin or something like that
can we bring somebody do we have anybody
or oh this is merch for bunk c all over
again what's merch for bunk c i don't
know
wait is that one word merch for bunksy
no no no bunk c when you were shipping
off
shirts to sleep away yeah i didn't want
to say that this seems like you trying
to horn your [ __ ] niece or nephew
into my trip that's what it sounds it
sounds like you owe your nephew money
yeah listen what if like my uh 22 year
old bookmaker nephew
decided to come with us
you stink
the more let me guess you got a nephew
who will volunteer the morrisons are a
family of five and they're lovely people
and the juice is running
listen if we can do that trip this
weekend that'd be great
hey neither one of us can go yeah it
really helped me out yeah it really
helped me out of a pinch
[Laughter]
and listen they want to do 12 keep it
moving t-shirts
they want to do the water park as well
can one of them dance on shamu now hold
on a second
now hold on all right this also raises i
don't think you're gonna fit on any
rides ouch that's a thing this is what
i i also thought about this can we
google disney for fat people
google that's really fun yes uh we're
gonna get you we're gonna get you a
scooter
just for the video which is why i
thought when you said you wanted to do
epcot and something else i'm not doing a
scooter i'm a [ __ ]
i'm in the gym [ __ ] three times a
week what are you talking about you're
also a crown fried chicken
i googled disney for fatties and the
first thing that popped up is traveling
while fat walt disney world for fat
folks
yikes
we're talking heavy bites shout out to
it
uh fat.com this is why i think we should
do that for fat people buy fat people
i think we should do that [ __ ] star
wars thing you love star wars they have
the whole star wars park you walk around
you see something you can build your own
[ __ ] custom lightsaber we can put it
on the set
what's that cost
yeah pricing gets does it get nuts yeah
wait hold on that's not included
what the the star wars park it's not
included in um that's in what's the
that's in disney movie there's like a
hollywood one uh that's different it's
not the regular park no i i thought no
the star wars is in uh hollywood movies
or whatever it's in l.a no there's a
park called okay because i was cuz i
googled it to try and see if that was
there to suggest it uh-huh but then i
couldn't figure out if it was in
california or florida and then i finally
think that's what it was there's one of
both
yeah it's in whatever there's a movie
one and i forget what it's
called uh star wars park uh hollywood
studios
in walt disney world is its own park
jesus
so but listen if you're going to [ __ ]
if you're going to disney you got to do
the magic kingdom that's disney world
there's not a whole [ __ ] ton for you you
know for adults or whatever it's all a
magical place oh yeah you ain't fitting
on [ __ ] buddy really
what's it say for fatties.org yeah it's
mostly just this chick being real sad
about not being able to do stuff in
harry potter world and they had to be
asked to leave the harry potter world
listen you don't want to do the riot
everybody kept calling me hagrid
you little bastards i'll get you
hey fetter hagrid
odor oh god
am i too fat for disney it's a youtube
video
that has 121 000 views god damn ouch um
this is a couple months away though
march
well it's also
we're closed we're about we're about 50
or 60 i think we're about 60 away from
well
this guy's saying he's 6-1 and when he
was 390 pounds i was able to fit on
every ride i wanted to go on yeah that's
caveat
[Applause]
there was three kids riding him down the
log flume
i had to go as the log
but i did it
this guy was on the hoagie coaster what
are we talking about what the meatball
world
every ride everywhere they want it
yeah like the plane dude i was about
on first reading i didn't catch that i
was gonna be like i followed good jews
but then i was like also you're not a
coaster guy
i'm a huge coaster guy brah
coasters all day i'm like [ __ ] dan
cortez in this [ __ ] no you're not the
[ __ ] i'm not when was the last time you
rode a roller coaster
200 pounds ago but i used to love doing
it i have hit them all the great
adventure i love roller coasters okay
okay that's very new to me drugs in a
room in roller coasters now i'm learning
something about this goddamn guy
i would have never pegged you as a
coaster guy huge coaster guy i've ridden
them all you said a great adventure
that's about six great adventure hershey
park
uh i've ridden the cyclone at coney
island a bunch of times
the only thing you did at hershey park
is get stuck in a tube like augustus
i competed in the pia state wrestling
championships okay all right as well um
well i mean well the chances are you're
still waiting 200 pounds by
lost two in a row when i was going
can i help you
welcome back to my hotel room for
uh
i mean the thing is you got to plan
these out pretty far you can't just
[ __ ] you know
okay you can't just roll up i mean let's
take a kid
that way they can live like they they
can ride all the rides who who's kid i
don't want to spend a [ __ ] three days
with a kid okay hear me out it could be
one of your kids they've all been to
disney world twice we we bring the kids
with your sisters if you resent yourself
no way they would give me one of their
kids
also why why do i want that
responsibility that's insane because
it's a place for kids yes it's not a
place for fat middle-aged guys
i feel bad going yeah well you have a
lot of [ __ ] up things going on in your
head i can't help that i'll be
guaranteed too you get what i'm saying
yes and what i'm saying is we bring the
kid we don't bring him to the park we
leave him in the hotel room with a bag
of coke let that kid do drugs in a room
then we do a podcast with a child disney
versus drugs in a room that's pretty
good get a kid we're not taking a kid
man
14 15
that's too old no we're going the thing
is to take you to disney
i just feel bad
why
because i'm an adult i feel bad for like
my
nephews and my nieces time to get their
[ __ ] act together get a patreon
cooking they can do whatever the [ __ ]
they want
come on my mom can i bring my mom
patty patty
me and patty we'll get our own room
we'll stay in a room together
no i don't want to hang out with your
mom for three days why don't i have well
i don't want to hang out with my mom for
three days
toby what should you want to take an
older woman to put me that doesn't make
any
sense be the youngest person or the
oldest person yeah my mom likes disney
she's been but hasn't taken you she went
with her girlfriends like maybe like 15
years ago oh my god
we didn't have disney money growing up
it went with the girlfriends 15 years
ago yeah we barely had summer's point
new jersey money how much points got
some cash though
yeah you're not standing on the beach no
you're over at circle liquor like a
turquoise she's staying inland um over
there in egg harbor like a bozo eht
shout out
uh yeah you can't we're not bringing a
kid the thing is you going that's the
whole thing and it's also like you
dropped this [ __ ] now when we're [ __ ]
40 people all right fine so when are we
going i said the end of march and then
let's just fill it out i won't be able
to go to all the parks
okay that's very expensive except for
harry potter that what's this guy
[ __ ] ripping us off yes
i thought it was all one place that's
the whole thing it's a giant rip-off i
thought this was all one place
whether it's a hundred two hundred bucks
disney world here you go
enjoy you get to see the harry potter
there's four theme parks
magic kingdom epcot hollywood studios
and animal kingdom animal kingdom's
pretty good time yeah those monkeys get
after it
that monkey cage is something else so
it's a world in there we got to do that
too baby i've been in a monkey cage
that's a good reckless
um
you've been in a cage with monkeys no
i've been in a monkey cage i like a zoo
oh i thought you meant they mistake them
for a gorilla one time
trying to ship me to singapore
i had to prove myself to the rest of the
rest of the pride they're still tracking
me with a chip
that's why when i fight i got ready for
the testicles
um
yeah i mean i would say or maybe we just
you want to do the two major ones are
magic kingdom and epcot
right magic kingdom is disney world like
or disneyland whatever the [ __ ] that's
like the one right
then there's epcot which is like
the globe which is also like iconic
right
i mean what ones do you want to do what
about the animal kingdom is that
separate give me the four again i just
did magic kingdom epcot disney hollywood
studios disney's animal kingdom
where's the water park
two water adventure parks disney
blizzard beach and disney typhoon lagoon
but you can like add them on as a
package
listen i'm not getting top of it i'm not
getting to the top of [ __ ] shotgun
falls and having to watch you walk back
down the stairs
okay it's not my head we're edging our
bets here
were you too fat no i pissed myself on
the way up i said everybody i don't like
those i don't like those enclosed uh
tubes either
i'm not a big fan of you
uh
so i think get some plex or something in
here
you better have a big plunger that's oh
i would if i ever got stuck
if i ever got stuck in something like
that i would freak the [ __ ] if my arms
were pinned
little kids coming down on you
um
your mom listen it's also like
i i'm the kind of guy where i go like if
you go to disney and don't go to the
magic kingdom it's kind of like what's
the photo opportunity in there are you
not allowed to take pictures you are
right no yeah you can film on your cell
phone and all that stuff yeah we're
going to have your t-bone's gonna have
to go with a uh light crew yeah i'm
thinking
i'm thinking a three-man job
i actually are the wheel man i already
have the plan in my head i mean you
that's just you're allowed to film and
take pictures so like if you just bring
a camera in a camera case like this is
my personal camera the the move is you
put the you put a camera strap on the on
one of these yeah yeah and then it hangs
on your neck people think you're taking
photos yeah yeah shoot video yeah yeah
for sure and probably 360 camera and
then cell phone your cell phone you
should be fine
okay uh
also like
there's not much at magic kingdom that i
remember as like an adult like i went
you know i don't know four or five years
ago or something like that with my
family
see i would feel okay
i feel we can do epcot we for sure have
to do epcot that's where you like drinks
let's do epcot and disney because i'll
tell you what if i went to i would feel
strange as a as a grown man going to
star wars and having a good time without
like my nephew i would feel like a piece
of [ __ ]
okay seems like layers of stuff going on
there but sure we'll get into
uh yeah so
but like there's nothing at the magic
kingdom other than like fine let's go to
the animal kingdom if we did epcot in
the animal kingdom that'll be that would
be fun if we if you guys got [ __ ] housed
and then we went to the animal kingdom
well that's the thing you got to do i'm
not trying to get arrested in orlando
you ever seen you know how hard you have
to work to get arrested and land out
though
i do a lot more drugs in a room i'll
tell you that much
drugs in a monkey cage
[Laughter]
drug with drugs with a zebra looking at
you
hey man you're up
[Laughter]
you know any chicks out here
[Music]
that's why he's the
boss oh man
isn't it pretty crazy this show's behind
a pen this show's better than ayg
[Laughter]
man the visual i got on that
no he was sitting next to me in the
backseat of the car for some reason
really i was in a hotel room i was i was
in the middle
and we were doing it he was in the car
with us while we were on safari doing
coke
and i was like holding the mirror in the
straw and he was just next to me looking
ahead
sitting up like a human
ah that's a good good
job
what we should do animal kingdom for
sure all right animal kingdom we'll do
we'll we'll do early in the morning like
we'll do first half of the day because
then it's also uh it's pretty expensive
per day per person we'll do it all in
one day let's go to [ __ ] animal
kingdom and then do epcot in the
afternoon what's that give me a number
two something ahead
200 ahead 215 ahead 220 ahead that total
for both parks yeah that's the park
hopper patch so you got me you toby
mm-hmm so that's six bills right there
and then we need seven but yeah we need
a hotel for tonight no well we're gonna
do that do do a house right yeah stay at
a house that way you [ __ ] hang you
stretch out you got the pool stay in the
house for a couple of days yeah do like
two three days down there
what the hell are we gonna do the rest
of the time what do you mean [ __ ]
chill you got the pool go out to dinner
[ __ ] hang relax little r r foley all
right you've heard of drugs in a room
from the makers of
that wearing drugs in the pool yeah dude
it's kind of [ __ ] i've done drugs i
love drugs in the pool it's got a hot
tub i like drugs on the steakhouse too
what i'm saying so he's got a [ __ ]
espresso a little zambooka the guy comes
in you run the bathroom you come out now
i'm good
that smoke after that's nice why not
it's gonna be like
you know
it'll be after
it'll be after pittsburgh i think or
buffalo or something like that
oh somewhere cold
well like why not just go [ __ ] we're
going down there why not take a day or
two to [ __ ] just chill for ourselves
okay also we'll shoot [ __ ] content in
the [ __ ] house we can do a [ __ ]
bonus or two from there and stuff and
like [ __ ] have a house we got a
[ __ ] pool we got a hot tub we got a
grill and go out to dinner get a car for
two days
okay i can do it let's [ __ ] do it
what are we doing here all right
animal kingdom epcot
animal kingdom
epcot
knock that knock out disney in a day and
then we'll take a day for us i can't go
into the magic kingdom take a picture in
front of the castle is that what you're
looking for well i think that's what
everybody would want that's what
everyone thinks i was thinking that like
that and like the fire do they do the
fireworks in florida like you do in
california at yeah but that's at magic
kingdom at night
what do those three things run us uh
there's enough time in a day to do yeah
so even even trying to get two in a day
here we go why don't we do animal
kingdom and uh
magic kingdom not an animal king it's
not going to be like [ __ ] uh tiger
what's it called tiger king i'm not
going to feel bad for these guys are
they i don't think so i mean it's like a
proper they do it nice they take care of
them down there
yeah i'm an animal lover i don't want to
get caught up in that
um
but you gotta do epcot too that's the
thing that's the ball
the what the ball the globe the ball oh
yeah yeah yeah all right
let's do all three of those
that's now we're talking two days i
don't think you can knock them all out
today no shot you'd have to do like two
hours at each one maybe
ugh
that's a lot of moving and grooving i i
mean i think two in a day based on like
the i mean i told you i watched that
documentary on the development of the
disney fast pass it's called it's
defunct land is the youtube channel
check it out it's [ __ ] awesome i have
an idea
it's going to be tough to get
[ __ ] two parks in a day
yeah well like also in a day these
things gonna be tough
you said there wasn't much a magic
kingdom we're just kind of blowing
through there to whatever let's do this
let's do magic kingdom and epcot center
in one day then the next morning we go
and do the animal kingdom and then we
[ __ ] kick back like hoes on melrose
for the next couple of days
because that's the fun thing we want to
do
or do we i don't even give a [ __ ] just
do epcot and uh
magic kingdom
i'll be happy
as long as i get some merch
i want to get a stuffed animal or
something like that sure those big
lollipops plus i hear the food down
there ain't too shabby
food's all right yeah food's all right
plus i got you know there's like
downtown disney which has like a couple
good steakhouses and stuff like that
skid row
get to real field
who wants to go for a ride in tent city
huh
i got shanked by a cop
that was a trip it was crazy man i suck
goofy's dick
i got beat on a couple bags of h
it was just
tobacco sounds like fun
yeah
so we'll look at it we'll finish up some
of the details or what we just go to the
star wars and i make you do the full
star wars experience where like we we're
like the jedi outfits and we walk around
like goobers the whole time i don't
think they'd let you in in a jedi outfit
what do you mean they wouldn't
well yeah they're real strict about
canon and stuff so you'd have to be a
hutt of some kind java or otherwise
kind of a fat serviceman that was a real
deep cut but for the star wars fans out
there i know you appreciated it
i know i did uh i don't think like kids
they'll they'll let dress up
oh really because they then they like
you look like i worked there i worked
there yeah and they don't want to they
do not want that you'll be in disney
jail
where's darth vader eating all that
pizza
standing in line for a turkey leg
you're in the monkey cage hey he's from
here originally
okay um yeah we can figure it out i'm
grateful i'm grateful for going of
course just saying i have a little a
little loud yeah i feel weird going
without a kid
yeah fair enough you know um
yeah we'll figure it out uh
but i got two tree things with this hard
feelings there you know what i mean lay
it on us you know what i mean um
so
uh we got uh
we ordered a new dresser right
you and the lady me and me and the bird
uh she ordered a dresser
ikea
no
[ __ ] bob's discount furniture you're
joking i swear to god with the cartoon
guy yeah
she ordered online without me knowing
and she doesn't know
that it's like a joke of a [ __ ]
cartoon on a cover i know
well she went online
whatever she doesn't know so i go she
goes i don't know how they have that
much money for those commercials by the
way either by the way it wasn't
do they do well it wasn't cheap it was a
[ __ ] expensive [ __ ] dresser how
much
sick something what the [ __ ] yeah it's a
very nice dresser my boy was a salesman
at a bob's discount furniture and he
said the worst part of the job was that
everyone would walk in and be like
discount what the [ __ ] is this yeah no
it's wildly expensive
that's how they get you in the door
straight click bait dude
cute cartoon and a discount yeah
then they get in there
[ __ ] they close like sharks they get
chalk blown in your eyes
it's like the mudder boys down at the
wharf
the one time i kept
the dead rabbits me and my boy were
shopping for a couch when we lived in
that townhouse in bucks county
and we walked we were like oh we got to
go to ken and every place you walked in
and we walk in and be like hey man
what's your zip code or like
what the [ __ ] so we like told and like
i'm that guy where i'm like i don't tell
you anything if people ask you you need
help i go just looking i'm picking on my
mom get it i ask you for your email now
with everything say mind your own
[ __ ] business
what's your email let me look you up
they stay they say it in a way of like
you're the [ __ ] if you don't give it
to them i know i finally found a way to
get around that i did i did htm the
other day i said you he said are you a
member i said i'm not and i'm not gonna
be and she went okay yeah move right
along yeah no and no thanks
yeah take it easy
um but so she she orders it
and um nope just nine pairs of black
jeans please
[Laughter]
what's your bed bug policy
we haven't gotten it i thought this was
on a public episode yeah we'll get to it
um
so i
god bless her she just doesn't
understand
things in new york are different than
things elsewhere
right like
convenience you got to pay for
convenience in new york you know what i
mean
and the delivery was going to be like
150 but they were going to come assemble
it like the white glove service or
whatever and she's like the thing was
already 600 bucks and then like another
like it came to like high sevens after
everything and she's like then tip in
she's like she didn't do it and she
wanted to surprise me with it is what
she wanted to she wanted to be like oh
here it is
here's a ruined tuesday night
you ain't wrong but it was saturday or
sunday
i would [ __ ] lose it so
i get the i get the call so she goes i
was supposed to do something
this week where i was gone i don't know
if it's like a recording day she was
going to take the car
get get it all loaded or whatever and
then like have it so i come home is she
gonna put it together
yeah or have one i guess one of the guy
i don't know okay so she wasn't setting
you up
no she was the the the idea for the
present or like finished finished here
you go all your clothes are in it
because we got rid of the one we had and
then we never [ __ ] replaced it i've
been living out of my closet and i
[ __ ] hate it it's like it's like we
have like a shelf like it's this whole
system but like
you're digging and then things don't it
stays neat for like a day
and then it just turns into [ __ ] cats
i'm like looking through things they're
falling i'm shoving and i'm getting
dressed i hate getting dressed already
because i'm a fair piece of [ __ ] changes
your whole [ __ ] your whole life
around when you organize and clean all
that stuff so we just so that every
morning i'm like can we get a [ __ ]
dress like i'll i'd lose it i'm like get
a [ __ ] dresser just pull the [ __ ]
tree i don't care what you get you get a
[ __ ] dresser real cool
[ __ ] haven't even had my cheerios yet
i'm a [ __ ] her hey i want a
frittata take the edge off um
so
uh
she that was the plan was all right i'm
gonna do it you know get it so it's all
set up have his clothes in there so he
comes home from recording or whatever
the [ __ ] i was doing
um
but then
she's like oh i'm going to pick it up
sunday do you want to go i was like yeah
i'll go
we get out there and i just go what
happened to the [ __ ] drop it off and
she was going to go get something
something happened where they weren't
going to get dropped off so she was
going to have to tell you this hey i
wanted to have this present for you but
it's not going to be until sunday you
want to go out she's like yeah i'm going
to go i'm like oh i'll go with you i was
just sitting at the [ __ ] house how
was she going to get there without
without you my car she was going to take
the car and go yeah oh really i don't
have her chained up yeah it's just a lot
of things to carry well
there's no way you could have not gone
you would look like a dirtbag of course
so like my arm's twisted a little bit
but that's also i don't mind um
it's in hoboken
or something secaucus that's where it is
trade over the bridge
sure about 22 minutes away i bed um
it's like all right we get over there
and uh it's [ __ ] freezing cold out
like proper freeze so you pull up to the
window oh this sunday yeah you
[ __ ]
freezing i didn't come out of my
apartment
it was bad at all i know so we pull up
to the [ __ ] we pull up to the front
door she runs in
hey you go going to this little like
pickup counter and then they tell you to
go back to like back into bait [ __ ]
two or whatever you know so we back up
there it's like 15 cars it's kind of
chaotic
you know this is a bob's this is a bob's
discount furniture not so disgusting you
already ordered so you just back she
ordered a paint i just got it back in so
i put the seats in the car down it's
gonna [ __ ] slide right in the trunk
trunks not gonna close i'll tie it up
[ __ ] out the door
um
the guy walks it out and he's just
walking down his ain't fitting in that
[ __ ] it's a big [ __ ] box so he's
like you want to unwrap it so we try to
get it in it's not it's not getting in
it won't slide it won't slide it won't
make that [ __ ] angle
we have it like vertical trying to get
i'm like this ain't it's [ __ ] heavy
it's freezing like so cold i have a
glass of that rider's teeth
this is [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] wild car weekend too i
know wild car weekend oh this might have
been saturday then i think this was
saturday wild card saturday yeah that
was two games the first were wrong yes
it wasn't sunday or saturday
so
yeah it was definitely saturday
um or friday whatever it doesn't matter
so freezing friday even though it was
saturday we went to beacon on friday um
it was freezing cold so he's like yeah
you want to unbox it and i go absolutely
no get this delivered i'll pay whatever
i have to pay for someone to [ __ ]
bring this to my house this is crazy i'm
not unboxing anything do you think your
hands are already hurting i'm like if
i'm like ripping open car but i'm like
no way said hey set it up he goes now
you can't set it up you can't set up
delivery you've already claimed it or
something at this point
i go that's nuts i go [ __ ] send it to
my house and he goes no go i'll pay
whatever he goes no no you can't i go so
if i go back inside they're going to
tell me they can't send it he goes yeah
he goes listen i got a guy
i go all right this sounds kind of up my
alley a little bit
i i like a guy
has he's done
time what's the finger tattoo situation
i like a guy
right he's done a nickel so he goes call
this years ago but he's done a nickel so
he goes call this so i call this number
uh
he doesn't answer
so
ishm the guy
who is an amazon prime year
yeah
this guy's a friend how can i direct
your call this guy's a friend of a
friend of bob's discount yeah
so
he goes how can i uh
so i go hey man i'm i'm not and also
like we were kind of me and the lady
were really bumping heads at this point
so i'm like hey man we're gonna wrap
this like
what are we doing
at this point i'll torch the thing i
don't care i'm just like hey man i'm
leaving
how can we get this he goes give me your
number uh so like i transferred numbers
with ishm the guys who was helping me
try to put it in the car and he goes ah
when he calls back well that we'll
figure this out i go all right see ya
hop in the car i'm on the bridge and i
get a call from the original guy the the
truck driver guy not the guy at bob's
big distance
not ishma
steve his boy steve's yeah ishma's boy
steve so steve goes
yeah what's up
so i'm thinking he's got the run down
from esham like hey you know i gave isha
my address everything's gonna get that
bedbug story ready because this is a
heater
sweeps week tell you that right now so i
go now he goes and get this accent's
thick and i'm on the speakerphone in the
car it's not fantastic and i'm like
i go yeah for bob's big boy or whatever
roy rogers and he's like what one i go
secaucus i go he goes all right send me
the paperwork and where are you i said
i'm right over the george washington
bridge and washington in new york and
washington heights okay just send it to
me no worries you know okay
he goes i need the paperwork they're not
going to give it to me without a picture
of the paperwork i'm like the [ __ ]
you know whatever talk to each other
that's what i'm saying so i go hey and
ishmam kept the paperwork so now it's a
panic we don't have the paperwork
eshma's got the paperwork issues got it
so i go easy goes i see send me a
picture of the paperwork i got to send
it to steve the driver yeah you got it
here bada bing so i go here's my address
here's my thing okay cool
he goes yeah maybe in like an hour and a
half like all right great
two hours goes by hey
i got it on the truck i got to make two
more stops and then i'm coming i'm
headed straight to you
no sweat baby i'm here all night
chilling you let me know
hour goes by at least two hours goes by
we're not like
yeah he said an hour and a half
originally we're now like four hours in
but again i'm not sweating has a price
been discussed 110 on the original
uh
the original call with him i said i'm in
washington nights here good no no where
he's 110 bucks i can do it throw a tip
150 you're out the door
uh
and he goes how many stairs does it have
to go up i go no stairs just get it
right inside the door i'll push it on
the [ __ ] elevator and we're you know
we're going from there cool
so then he hits me with the
uh
pole
yeah i got a call i didn't know you were
in new york
i go what do you mean you didn't know i
was in new york i texted you my address
zip city state zip code and all
i told you on the phone that i was right
over the george washington bridge in
washington heights
and i said new york and you said 110 he
goes they're gonna charge me 50 60 bucks
to get over there
on top of what i'm already paying
so i'm like so he goes i got
he goes but i already got it on the
truck and i went ooh you [ __ ] snake
which i think was a snake move i got it
on the truck i'm headed your way i
didn't real he got me hook line and
sinker with the 110.
then calls me with the up charge
of it's going to be another 40 bucks
so it was
so i'm like now also i don't know what
[ __ ] cash i got on me like you know
what i mean and i'm like
we i i made i made the one
50. but now i'm like i don't know what
else i have [ __ ] on me laying around
you know
nothing
so
you're actually oh my like there's honey
buns stacked around there no but i mean
at this point i got the i got the so i
go i got 150k but i gotta pull the
driver off you got nothing i'm saying i
got the nut cover though i'm like all
right well i'll i'll cover the toll
right yeah
and i was like but i don't know what
else i have [ __ ] i didn't have 20 or
so what did he say the final price was
he didn't he's like uh it's 110 they're
gonna charge me 50 for the toll so
you're 160. and i'm like all right and
he goes uh oh he did say he goes i guess
i was like all right man like
i can throw you more money like what are
you
you got me by the balls here steve you
got my [ __ ] product on the truck
you're headed to my what am i gonna tell
you bob's big boy ain't gonna take it
back and i doubt his real name was steve
it was not hiding it
it was bob
little boy
after all that you asked the guy you
ever meet bob
so how long have you known bob
uh but it was
my thing i'm like you got me i don't
have any option at this point which i
think was a move do you think that's a
grift
i don't know
you got a pretty dumb face i never i
never saw the guy i talked to him he
probably looked you up
this is my podcaster
that podcaster comedian
maybe this is my thing don't do this
maybe
maybe
i mean it's on the truck how do you not
look at
ah there's a lot [ __ ] wrong here
then all of a sudden it's on the truck
there's no option now he's either going
to leave it on the side of the road in
hoboken or he's got i got to pay the i
got to pay the troll toll
so
he goes i'll do it for this price which
was 110 was the original quoted price oh
he'll do it for that yeah so now i'm
like well i'm like i can throw you some
extra [ __ ] money yeah there you go i
had 160 that's a solid no then it wasn't
a grift
it's a grift if he doesn't i think he's
waiting for people to go well think
about it this way he quoted you 110.
there's no way anybody's charging just
110 knowing they're going to get whacked
over the head with a [ __ ] 60 hour
toll on the gw
for an hour's worth of work that's 70
that would be 70 bucks also i don't know
how much that hole is that toll could be
30 bucks i don't [ __ ] you ever drive
a tractor it was a like a box truck you
ever drive a box truck across the gw 40
50 bucks you don't know that toby
one axle unicycle um
check it out but whatever even i'm just
saying if it was that's i think that's
his way to go and
what can i get out of that i wasn't
barking orders he's happy he's happy to
do it for 110. i'll do it for 110.
but you're telling me at no point
did he look until he was at the gwb i
mean maybe he didn't you're not dealing
with [ __ ] uh what's his name
jp morrow what's it called jp uh
who's the guy with the mustache that
delivers office supplies wb mason yes
yeah that's a class operation uh yeah i
don't know it just felt very like what
do you got tobes uh this is only saying
stuff for five axles where you get
[ __ ] jacked over the head that's five
axles 95 there you go yeah i mean he was
no it wasn't a five axle it was like a
box truck
it's 30 bucks 30 40 yeah so i'm saying
30 if he's going it's going to cost me
55. he might have fled he might have
if it was an actual grift he would have
never bent on the 110.
either way you gave him the the thing
right
yeah i gave him like 155 or one sec
whatever i had on me
because i was expected for 110. [ __ ]
guy he said he jammed me up so i told my
wife he said just get from now on get
everything delivered all the time we're
never [ __ ] picking anything there's
no easy way to do it if they say it's
going to cost 150
that's what's going to cost time and
money insanity like i'm not taking a
train to a car to a guy to a thing to a
boat to a ferry to save 30. give me the
[ __ ] give the 150 out the door
they'll come and [ __ ] install it for
you meanwhile it was already [ __ ] put
together oh well it's all in one piece
oh nice this was a nice saving grace i
got to give you that well yeah that
would have been yeah that would open it
up we're like oh [ __ ] it's together cool
dunzo nice didn't put the lights that
could have been a divorce
you're just looking at planks of
unfinished wood yeah you gotta stain it
yourself
dude like what's got a beveler we put uh
i put the king size bed frame together
and i mean i'm not exaggerating there
was an extra bag like proper extra bag
of hardware and she's like what's this
for my god it's rid of blinds or
something so when you put it upside down
yeah throw those out
i'm like i don't know where to go i
don't know what to tell you
ah it's good stuff
it's good stuff
you got nothing to contribute we're
going to toby see if you can beat that
toby's in somebody you just don't bring
anything to the [ __ ] show well not
until we got two high story lines going
on here
okay told you i stayed in all day sunday
i don't know where i can really go with
that yeah my your new homework is to
[ __ ] not stay in a room and do drugs
go live a life go to the park
go rock climbing go for a hike do
something i'm doing all that stuff i'm
out [ __ ] getting rock climbing is
what you're telling me i took the subway
here
that's why i know that one yeah because
i know there was no train delay by the
way no there was busted cold i took the
same train you did i was like taking the
seven because i was coming from the
hotel i saw you on the train
you you don't take the train he took the
train today i think i i genuinely think
his parents took his car no
because there has there's been that idea
has been kicking around a little bit
you've been asking me about my personal
lease on my car
car's fine i'm trying not to use it that
much
because of uh it's getting close to the
end of the lease
and you are over you got to be over no
i'm not over yet i have 5 000 miles left
on it when's the lease of 2028 december
of december of this year
whole year so 12 wait 12 oh my god
five thousand
five thousand miles ten and a half years
oh i love this
you're back on the street did you take
an uber from the train station no take
an uber well
it's a two-parter uber got your tongue
what happened
on my off days when i'm not at the gym i
have to accumulate 10 000 steps
and it's been
hard to do that did i buy them off my
neighbor it's been hard to do that by
driving it like say i would
say like say i would drive into work
drive home and then walk up to the gym
walk on the treadmill for a half an hour
and then walk back that still isn't it's
now you're going to take an hour to walk
around a track when you could just walk
to places in your life
exactly yeah and they're hard they're
hard steps too
up the stairs down the stairs tell you
you get out of subway shape really quick
i'm sure it's [ __ ] brutal i don't i
haven't taken in a while oh they killed
that girl yesterday what yeah guy pushed
her on the track killed her two cops
were on the platform why
sent her to meet god or something like
that jesus yeah that sucks
he was all smiles on the way out too
who was the guy a little cuckoo bananas
what are you working in the crime report
what's going on i read the paper and
jimmy olsen over here i read the paper
you don't read the paper
you don't read there's no way you get a
paper delivered to your house i do
which one the new york times no you my
wife does i swear to god everything and
the new yorker we subscribe to real
learned manhattanites
gotta start getting the new yorker
mainly lay it down so i can [ __ ] in the
living room
[Laughter]
no she gets to new york i don't get the
new york times
we've gotten one new yorker
wait
you're double talking me here do you get
the new york times or not
you get the new yorker yeah we've gotten
one issue off the new york new york
magazine no best brunch spots around
soho no we get to new yorker the heavy
hitting hard pieces
she does she wanted in a raffle or
something i don't know
i haven't read it she picked it up i'm
more of a i'm more of a tick-tock man
myself
a couple of years ago but still
anywho what
forget about we got two hot story lines
let's switch he's got to save it we're
done i think right are we
okay
this is what i'll say and he's slipped
can i just can i just ask
where the cat is right now the cat is
holed up in a holiday inn express by the
airport and parts unknown in queens so i
assume that he's all hopped up on skaggs
can i ask you this did you go behind the
bed and make sure there was no holes in
the walls and all that [ __ ]
yeah the bed there's no way for him to
get under the bed the he did great
honestly could you put the privacy sign
on the front door of course nice
tv on
no
what if he's in there crying
are you allowed to have pets in this
jump yes
i was supposed to we were supposed to be
yesterday within the [ __ ] it's a
holiday inn at the airport it's not it's
near the airport it's your jfk i guess
it's on queens boulevard and whatever
61st
i know that holiday
the
inn
breakfast
we just say they're not real eggs
yeah it was supposed to be yesterday but
then the [ __ ] exterminators cancelled
i called them called them up lost it uh
i've never yelled at customer service
people before really you did it today
about an hour ago
y'all i was more faster than jersey
mike's
i was i was crazy and i want to talk to
mike
[Laughter]
uh
yeah no i lost it because i called it i
woke up i didn't go to sleep because i
was making sure everything in the
apartment was absolutely gone my
apartment is insane right now and inside
of my apartment is a couch which after
this i'm gonna go disassemble and throw
out
uh there's a tv stand with my tv on it
xbox couple cameras
some pictures on the wall
end of list jesus christ toothbrush
i think they have to wait another month
too right now they're coming back in a
week
and then after that spray you can you're
good to you're good yeah the and then
one of the i think the the the pest
control dude who came in this morning
and saw the place he was like where
where are they or where's the man i
threw everything out and he was like i
have never seen this before i'm crazy
man i was like yeah dude extreme
prejudice bro go to the go to orbit and
nuke it did you ask him hey can i start
moving my stuff back in
i would have asked him so you're not
waiting another week i'm pretty sure
you're clean
yeah yeah we're we're not dealing in
pretty sure we're dealing in absolutes
this is how you win it's been living
like a [ __ ] spy
christopher five weeks
yeah
look this is how dude but here's the
thing so i've gotten rid of all my
worldly goods i'm like a monk now wait
hold on if you get rid of the couch
tonight what are you gonna sleep on i'm
gonna get an air mattress
hang upside down in the shower
and then we're gonna kick it on that air
mattress then we're gonna get that other
spray we're gonna [ __ ] make sure the
coast is clear and i'm gonna get a few
things but i plan on continuing a very
thin existence in that apartment to like
get a new place you gotta get out of
that place i gotta get out what are you
doing i'm gonna call the guy today yeah
just say hey listen
my financial
position has changed don't say for the
better for the worse they say my
financial situation has changed
uh
i need to i need to move out and they'll
go please because they can't evict in
new york city
they just extended it i believe
and they can't hit my credit or [ __ ] me
up in some way no no then why don't you
sign a lease what do you mean
they can
the only time you can sign the only time
make sure you're getting your deposit
back too yeah do the only time they'll
[ __ ]
it'll go against your credit or like a
judgment is if you refuse to pay rent
okay if you go hey i'm out of here and
he goes yeah please you know lisa's
terminator or help me find someone new
or whatever that's fine
um
but yeah just yeah i mean i did the same
thing i said hey i'm [ __ ] out of here
look it's all good that's your stuff man
you're just going through your your your
dark new york moment yeah dude i'm going
to come out a beautiful a beautiful
little butterfly
it ain't so bad so far i get to rebuild
from the ground up i take that back
sorry
you guys watching too much gary vee
forgot about that one little caveat
i apologize
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't either his girlfriend passing away
what happened
let's wrap it up guys we love you we
love you